Let's go next to
wait. Hold on. I wanted to go to Herschel in
Denver, Herschel in Denver. You're on the air.
David, how's it going? Good,
how are you? Doing pretty good.
Good. Thanks for answering my call. I just had
a like it's been so unhealthy just talking about
all the time. And I was really interested to
know as as progressives, are there some House
representatives were elected to that or that were
elected that we should be really excited about?
Yeah, Jamal Bowman is interesting. Cory
Bush, I mean, there's there's quite a
list and we're going to be reviewing it. But,
you know, I think that the house is a mixed
bag because so far Democrats actually lost
seats, but there were some interesting wins
as well. So there's a lot to go over and
we'll do a full breakdown of the house soon.
Great. I really appreciate your commentary
on election night that I was a voice of
reason for my family. I just kept telling,
hey, just just wait it out, wait to long.
I really appreciate that. And just out
of curiosity, are you stacking bricks?
And they said, yeah, are you doing
some kind of construction work? No,
I wasn't. I was just banging
on my workstation here.
Oh, OK. Very good. Kind of like
when Trump slams the lectern.
That's right. Same idea. Very good. I
really drive upwards of I like it well
enough points up, points taken. All right,
my friend, I appreciate the call. Thank you.
Great to hear from folks all over. Really
all over. And we could go. You should see
there's countries here. Donald Trump
hasn't even heard of that we could go
to. Let me go next to Christina from Texas.
Christina from Texas. You're on the air.
OK, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Wow. Oh, my gosh, how exciting.
Well, as you know, Texas and being from Houston is
really big in oil and gas. And being a progressive
working in oil and gas is definitely tough,
especially with these times right now and really
vocal about their opinions. And now, kind of
like the previous caller, it feels like unhealthy
to keep hearing it and talking about it. So I was
wondering how you would go about it, especially if
maybe your coworkers enjoy talking about that
stuff and how we would deal with that. I guess.
I mean, I would probably take a very light touch
and just not participate in the conversations. Are
people deliberately pulling you into political
conversations you don't want to have?
Yeah, I feel like definitely like my
boss will come and talk about it and, you know, it
feels like I need to stand up because, you know,
it's very ignorant comments and.
So it sounds almost
like you're you're mixed because on the one hand,
you don't even want to be talking about politics.
But on the other hand, when
you hear ridiculous nonsense,
you don't feel great about just allowing it to get
by unchallenged. Correct? That is tough. I don't
know. I don't know what I would
do in that case. I mean, I think
if you wanted to simultaneously make a point that
you disagree but not really engage, you could say,
hey, you know what, I don't agree at all with you
on that. And millions of people don't. But I just
don't even really want to engage because I want to
get my work done. And I don't know. I mean, that
would be tough, particularly if it's your
boss. I don't know that I have good advice.
Well, actually, that's really helpful.
I think I'll try that, Dorothy.
All right. Well, let me know how it
works. Yes, thanks. All right. Great
to hear from you. There was a Christian
from Houston. Very, very exciting stuff.